[Music]
do you think relational intelligence is
more important than ever given you know
we live in very polarizing times I mean
know that this is kind of bleeding into
the workplace and every client that I
work with where dialogue has really in
some ways stopped because I think people
don't have this kind of intelligence
because these are the tools where we
keep the door open these are the tools
where we are curious with no agenda
about establishing a connection with
others and it's I think it's a it's
difficult because feelings are running
high and that that sort of I'm going to
square off against yes is is an easy
energy I think the harder energy is
staying with and staying in absolutely
something where you made you may feel
there's a disagreement that feels
personal or emotional etc so so what
kind of advice do you find yourself
giving like these days in particular
given that the stakes feel higher and it
almost is like the toughest time I can
remember to build bridges yeah
absolutely I mean we I really feel this
I get now actually this is gonna sound
very odd I now get excited when I bump
up against a difference with someone
because it's an opportunity to practice
exactly what I preach which is stepping
into the conversation digging in and the
mantra that a carry that I would invite
you know anyone to use any possible
connection is what can I learn from this
experience how can I grow from this
experience if I hold that in my mind I
feel like I can get through anything
with anyone and it takes this
unbelievable courage to step in and dig
in and and and be willing to be which we
don't like in this culture at all
confused which changes your mindset
I love confusion and often in the team
setting we don't allow for confusion and
honestly when we bump up against
differences and when we start going out
go ahead what she said it's Tara bar
that guy over there I can't be you know
often what happens in those
circumstances is because we're looking
for quick answers we're looking for
people to be right all the time but any
group and or any team as they're working
through decisions or even in the family
systems we need to allow for confusion
and group confusion people being ok with
I don't quite get where she's coming
from her got what he said you know that
doesn't make sense to me that's ok step
into it move into it open up those doors
and ask them more and so I think that's
a huge part of it is we've gotten very
slick in how we expect people to be this
performance kind of mindset yeah
and confusion is a really necessary part
of relating to one another well because
you won't understand each other you know
even people who have a huge amount in
common mmm they will bump up against
each other's differences so it's about
willingness to discover to be awkward
for a minute that's ok
love awkwardness you find yourself
confused instead of judging yourself or
judging them huh wonder why that is
yeah and it feels like the speed the
speed of business right is sort of
almost counter to what you're talking
about because you've got to leave time
to be confused and time to dive in and
time to explore and yet we live in this
like you said a performance-based
expectation culture where we deliver
deliver deliver and I feel like it's a
binary that's a binary and yet it leaves
so much behind right so we might make a
decision right but we might not have
heard all the input and we may not have
dealt with the cognitive dissonance that
what I call the creative abrasion
between people and we had we didn't then
give ourselves time to develop the
skills for the next time as well -
welcome welcome different viewpoints and
go through the process of reconciliation
absolute so you know it seems it's sort
of at odds with the world that we are
being held accountable to be successful
in - so how do we build in time to
practice relational intelligence you
know in this sort of
fast-paced frenetic fewer resources kind
of world I don't think we can afford not
to right and it's not even necessarily
about time it really is about our
mindset and our approach to one another
we all like to think we're open-minded
and to me our challenge is all to be
open-minded means openness of
perspective of not willing to be so ok
the here's the agenda item okay we got
that decision made okay this is done we
get so much satisfaction about checking
things off the list that we don't check
those things off well and with attention
and so it's not even necessarily a time
thing it's it's openness and when you
talk about diversity of perspective it's
also giving time to really step back and
say what perspective is missing you know
we tend to tribe and Eve and we tend to
you know be on this fast track train but
I think the more people practice this
you know as I mentioned before I get
excited when I bump up against a
difference with someone it can be a
difference of anything because it gives
me a chance to practice this willingness
to go ah I wonder what's really
important to them in this moment are
they willing to listen to what's
important to me and well it seems to
take time it actually accelerates the
effectiveness of the decision the
effectiveness of the outcome absolutely
so it's retraining how we're actually
you know thinking about time yes it's
not such a linear process it's more of
okay what is our engagement here look
like so we can produce the read and you
know the the absolute best result we
could it's really quality over quantity
yeah it's so slow to go fast or slow to
go best you know and ultimately we go
fast faster together and the quality of
our output is going to be better and how
we got there is going to feel that we
were honored yeah right versus making a
decision going forward just for the sake
of going forward yeah right so I mean
this is so classic it's like a classic
business dynamic
it really matters it really matters
[Music]
you